l'histoire d'un français d'un anglais et
d'un Algérien sans prisonnier
excusez-moi et ils sont ils sont
emprisonnés dans des dans les cellules
du sale ancienne des western là où il y
a les barreaux il décide de s'enfuir
mais seulement pendant le sommeil du
gardien parce qu'il y a un gardien
devant la séduit donc le soir arrive le
gardien commence à s'endormir français
qui va et il arrive à ouvrir la cellule
il sort il fait du bruit arrivant
arriver devant le gardien qui va là le
français fait miaou vous dire le fait
mieux que moi
il réussit le gardien dit c'est bon
c'est un chat c'est bon français réussi
à s'échapper l'anglais il va pareil il
arrive dans le gardien il fait du bruit
regardez qui va là
c'est bon c'est un chat c'est bon
l'anglais réussir à s'évader j'ai arrive
le génie il arrive dans le gardien il
fait du bruit il y en a dit qui va là si
[Applaudissements]